alright let's get started so I'm
starting with this video here what's
happening here is there's this mouse and
you see there's like this fiber-optic
cable going into its brain and the mouse
is asleep right now
and now the researchers are shining
light into its brain a specific region
of the brain to activate specific
neurons in order to test whether they
function and arousal and here you see
the mouse is going to wake up there it
goes it's awake now okay so for today's
lecture we're gonna sort work towards
understanding how this experiment works
and we're gonna talk about how neurons
function and how researchers are able to
control that function in order to modify
behavior in this case the arousal of
this mouse okay so this is going to
involved a particular type of cell in
our body which is the neuron and neurons
are highly specialized cells that have a
function to transmit information from
one part of the body to another okay and
so neurons are highly polarized cells
which you can see here on the left of
this neuron you see this Arbor of
protrusions which are called dendrites
and then on this side of the cell body
you see a single extension which is an
axon and then the terminus of the axon
over here and this nerve cell transmits
information in a single direction it'll
transmit information from this side to
this side okay and these neurons are
able to communicate with the each other
and they communicate at the ends of the
neuron which are known as synapses which
I'll come back to and talk about later
on in the lecture ok so neurons could be
making synapses on this side and also
making synapses on this side with other
neurons
okay so to start to unpack the function
of this neuron and I should highlight
that this this flow of information can
occur over very long distances right
your sciatic nerve extends from the base
of your spine all the way down into your
foot okay so that axon is a 1 meter in
length so that's an extremely long
distance to transmit information along a
single cell and so we're gonna go from
thinking about how signals are
transmitted in single cells and this
will evolve electrical sing signaling
then we'll talk about synapses and how
synapses function to communicate between
neurons and this is going to involve
also sort of understanding how certain
antidepressants like prozac work and
then we'll end by talking about how
researchers did this experiment to wake
up the mouse and it all starts with
something that I told you about at the
beginning of the semester which is that
there the plasma membrane separates
distinct compartments the outside of the
cell from the cytoplasm and there are
distinct ion concentrations on either
side of this boundary okay so we're
starting now talking about a single
neuron cell and we're going to talk
about a type of signal known as an
electrical passion potential so we're
going to talk about an action potential
and what an action potential is is this
an electrical signal that travels the
length of the neuron okay so this action
potential I'll abbreviate this ap so
when I refer to AP I'm not referring to
Advanced Placement but action potential
okay so this is an electrical signal
that travels the length of the axon in
the neuron and so in order to have an
electrical signal propagate we need some
sort of electrical property that the
cell has that enables this and so I
showed you or I told you earlier in this
aster how sodium ions are concentrated
on the outside of the cell and potassium
ions are concentrated on the inside you
see here's the sodium gradient here
potassium gradient here and now I'm
gonna tell you how it is that this
happens because this is
thermodynamically not favored right
these these ions would prefer by
diffusion to be equal concentrations on
both sides of this plasma membrane which
means that the cell to shift this from
equilibrium has to expend energy to set
up this situation and so in the plasma
membrane of the cell there is a protein
it's an integral membrane protein and
sits inside the plasma membrane so this
here is the plasma membrane and this
integral membrane protein is called a
sodium potassium ATPase so it's going to
have a subunit that hydrolyzes ATP to
adp and the protein uses the energy of
ATP hydrolysis to pump sodium ions up
their concentration gradient so the
sodium ions are going out of the cell
and this is going against the flow that
sodium would normally like to take which
would be going downstream and it pumps
potassium ions into the cytoplasm such
that there's a higher concentration of
potassium ions in the cytoplasm okay so
these neurons expend a huge about a
quarter amount a quarter of their ATP is
used by pumping ions like this such that
there is gradients of ions across the
plasma membrane okay
now if if one sodium ion was pumped out
for every potassium ion pumped in
there'd be no charge difference between
the exterior and the cytoplasm but what
happens in the plasma membrane is that
in addition to the sodium potassium
ATPase there are other channels that are
present there are sodium channels these
are mostly closed but there are some
potassium channels that are leaky and
they're basically leaking potassium from
the cytoplasm out into the ectoplasm
okay and if you have positive charges
going out the cell then the inside of
the membrane is going to have a net
negative charge and the outside of the
membrane is going to have a net positive
charge okay and this charge across the
membrane where you have positive on the
outside and minus on the inside I should
label this exterior and this is
cytoplasm this voltage difference is
known as the membrane potential okay so
this is a membrane potential
and it's an electrical potential across
the membrane if you're an electrical
engineer you can think of the plasma
membrane as a capacitor okay so this
plasma membrane is holding this charge
difference across it okay and so there's
a voltage across the membrane and in an
arresting state the cell's resting
potential is negative 70 millivolts okay
so if the cell is not getting stimulated
by something like a neurotransmitter the
resting potential is negative 70
millivolts where the inside is negative
and outside is positive okay
so now I just wanted to find some terms
that are gonna be useful for us when we
talk about action potentials so when
there's this negative inside potential a
negative inside potential is referred to
as polarized so it's polarized because
there's a polarity across this membrane
where one side is positive and the other
side is negative okay
so polarized refers to if there's a
negative inside potential so the resting
state of the side is there's a polarized
it's polarized however the cell can lose
this polarity and not have a charge
differential or it can flip and be
positive on the inside and when that
happens if there's either zero or
positive inside potential this is
referred to as depolarized
okay anyone have an idea as to how the
cell would flip the potential what would
have to happen in the plasma membrane to
flip this potential and depolarize the
cell yes Steven so Steven suggested
opening ion channels which ion channels
would you open yeah so Steven suggested
if you open these is going to depolarize
the cell because remember sodium is high
on the outside out here and so if you
open these channels positive ions are
gonna flow in and that's going to make
this less negative and this less
positive okay so this is the situation
here right where these sodium channels
open and the sodium channels are the
sodium ions rushing in is going to
create a depolarization where you now
flip the potential and there's a greater
positive charge on the inside of the
plasma membrane
okay everyone see how because the sodium
ions are going to just go downstream
their higher concentration out here so
just by opening these channels the cell
doesn't have to do any work to do this
sodium is just going to flow down its
gradient into the cytoplasm
okay so what an action potential is is
it's a transient dope depolarization of
the nerve cell okay so the action
potential or ap is a transient
depolarization of the neuron which means
it doesn't just depolarize and stay
depolarized
but it depolarizes and then restores
itself back to the resting polarity and
so what you see when you measure the
voltage across the plasma membrane in
the neuron you see that it can spike and
depolarize but then it's rapidly
restored to its resting state okay so
it's a transient process and when we
think about the neuron at higher
resolution what you're going to see is
not only is it transient but it's also a
traveling wave that propagates along the
entire length of the cell okay so this
is also a traveling wave and one thing
that you can notice about these neurons
or the action potentials here is that
they all depolarize to the same extent
so they all depolarize to this positive
50 millivolts and so this illustrates a
key property of neurons and that the the
level of activity of a neuron is not
determined by the size of this action
potential this action potential is an
all-or-nothing event it either happens
or it doesn't and when it happens it
depolarizes to the same level okay so
the action potential is all or nothing
you can think of it as a binary signal
and therefore the way that neurons
encode sort of the magnitude of
activation is not through the level of
depolarization of a single action
potential but it is able to distinguish
between different frequencies of action
potentials that are propagating along
the neuron
okay so signal strength in this case is
related to the frequency of action
potentials firing
okay so now we're gonna unpack how it is
a nerve cell fires in action potential
and how it propagates along the entire
cell length right in the case of the
sciatic nerve this has to happen across
an entire meter okay that's a very long
distance to propagate this change in
electrical signal at least for a cell
and so we're going to talk about the
mechanism and I'm going to start at the
beginning when this action potential
initiates so we'll start at the
initiation of the action potential so
how is it that this nerve cell is told
to start depolarizing at the dendrites
okay because there's gonna be another
neuron here which is going to
communicate to this neuron over here to
tell it to start depolarizing okay it
does this at the location known as the
synapse which is basically the sort of
the connection between the two neurons
and the way this process is initiated is
similar to the type of signaling that
you saw in the past few lectures where
you have a ligand and a receptor okay in
this case the ligand
the ligand is going to be what's known
as a neurotransmitter which is a small
molecule and I'll show you some later on
and the receptor is going to be a
receptor the binds to this log and but
in this case rather than being something
like a g-protein coupled receptor or a
receptor tyrosine kinase the receptor is
going to be an ion channel okay so the
receptor is going to be an ion channel
okay and so you see one example on the
slide up here where here's a receptor
and these receptors are what are known
as ligand gated sodium or ion channels
in this case it's a sodium channel so
it's going to be whether or not it's
open depends on the presence of the
ligand so if we take a neurotransmitter
like serotonin if it's not bound to the
receptor the receptor is closed but if
serotonin binds to this receptor it
opens up the channel which can
selectively let in a type of ion in this
case sodium right in this case this is
an activating channel because letting in
sodium is going to depolarize the cell
okay so this ligand receptor binding
uses a ligand gated there's a ligand
gated sodium channel and it's this
ligand gated sodium channel which starts
the depolarization
okay so that's how that's how you sort
of like knock over the first domino
right but then there has to be some
mechanism to propagate this along the
length of a very long cell and so I'll
tell you this involves a different type
of sort of signaling mechanism from what
you're used to thinking about because
this involves a different type of an ion
channel and it's called a voltage-gated
and I'll breve eh
voltage-gated just VG and in this case
it'll be a sodium channel okay so what's
a voltage-gated sodium channel this is a
voltage-gated sodium channel here and
you can see in the resting state of the
cell this channel is closed and it's
closed because of this red rod structure
that's positively charged
that's a positively charged alpha helix
that is a part of this protein is and is
embedded in the membrane but this alpha
helix is is positioned down towards the
cytoplasm because it's positively
charged and the cytosolic face of the
plasma membrane is negatively charged
okay and the confirmation of this
protein then depends on the charge
across this membrane because when
there's depolarization that shifts the
position of this alpha helix such that
now it shifts up towards the exterior
face of the plasma membrane and that
opens the channel which lets sodium ions
rush in okay okay again sodium ions here
they're always rushing downstream
they're on their concentration gradient
okay so in this case whether or not this
channel is open or closed depends not on
the presence of a ligand but on the
membrane potential across the plasma
membrane okay so these voltage-gated
sodium channels they're opened
by depolarization okay and then the
question becomes if you open these
channels at the very end of the neuron
how do you get it such that this
electrical signal moves uni-directional
II along the neuron okay so what leads
to you need directionality
okay who's been to a sporting event
light lately okay good you guys know the
wave okay so we're gonna do the wave
once you stand up you're gonna be tired
and you're gonna have to sit down for a
while okay I'm going to be a ligand volt
I'm the ligand gated sodium channel so
I'm gonna start things off okay you
ready
alright here we go
okay that's basically an action
potential okay so the way that this
happened that this was uni-directional
right is once you once you stood up and
did the wave right you then sat down and
you stopped doing anything okay
and so these voltage-gated sodium
channels have a similar property okay if
we look at the next step in this the
sodium channel is opened by
depolarization and you see there's this
ball of chain segment of the protein
whether you see that yellow ball and
once the sodium channel opens after
about a millisecond that ball sticks in
the channel pore and blocks it okay so
these sodium channels open to let in
sodium ions but then they're immediately
inactivated after about a millisecond
okay and so that enables uni-directional
'ti okay so this is what I'll call
voltage-gated sodium channel
inactivation okay and how this promotes
a travelling wave of depolarization is
that if we consider an action potential
moving along this axon from left to
right and if the sodium channels in the
green zone are currently open it came
from the left which means that all the
sodium channels to the left of this
green zone are going to be inactivated
okay so because they're inactivated here
there won't be further deep polarization
going to the left but depolarization
will have to move to the right and you
basically get this traveling wave and it
goes one direction because if it came
from somewhere which it always does then
where it just was coming from all those
sodium channels the voltage-gated sodium
channels are going to be closed okay so
this allows it to move in a
single direction along the neuron also
once the action potential gets to the
end of the neuron it doesn't reflect
back the other way in the neuron this
can only go one direction okay so this
provides you need directionality okay so
it's this inactive or refractory period
of the voltage-gated sodium channel
which prevents the action potential from
moving backwards okay now if you look at
these action potentials in this cell you
see that they happen but you don't just
depolarize and stay depolarized the cell
depolarizes and then repolarizes very
rapidly
okay so there's an oscillation okay so
there has to be some way to terminate
the action potential so there's a t
termination or repolarization of the
cell so there has to be a way for this
nerve cell to rapidly restore membrane
potential and I want you to think for
just a couple seconds about what type of
channel will might you open to
reestablish this polarity what ion do
you need to flow from where to where in
order to get a net negative charge on
the inside who don't
[Music]
okay you could pump the sodium ions out
and that's totally accurate so that's
going to require moving sodium ions up a
concentration gradient which is going to
take energy and is going to be slow so
is there another option we could take
advantage of here to repolarize Rachel
so Rachel is suggested to moving the
potassium ions to the outside which is
how this is done
so remember potassium is high on the in
the cytoplasm low on the exo plasm and
therefore if you have a voltage-gated
potassium channel that's going to cause
a rush of positive ions out of the cell
and that will be able to restore the net
negative potential on the inside of the
cell okay so this termination or
repolarization Leeds is the result of
the opening of voltage-gated in this
case not sodium channels but potassium
channels when do you think these have to
open relative to the sodium channel
should they open right with the sodium
channel
karmen shaking your head no do you want
to explain your logic
exactly mm-hmm so a Carmen said is if
they open simultaneously you have sodium
flowing in your potassium flowing out
and that's not going to necessarily
change their charge okay so when would
these have to open relative to sodium
channels yeah Carmen so after it's
depolarized yeah so this has to be
delayed relative to the sodium channels
okay so this has to be delayed relative
to the voltage-gated sodium channels
right because if you're thinking about
this traveling wave of depolarization
the depolarization is going to be high
where the sodium channels are only
entering and then following that you
would have potassium ions getting pumped
out and basically repolarizing the cell
okay everyone see how you sort of you
get depolarization with sodium rushing
in and then after that you repolarize
with the potassium getting pumped out
right so here you have a spike and you
complete the cycle it can even get
hyperpolarized where it gets even more
negative than it normally does and then
it eventually gets back to this resting
potential of around negative 60 or
negative 70 millivolts
okay so this has to happen fast and I
want to tell you about one process or
property of neurons and another helpful
cell that enables this to go extremely
fast and that is that there are these
glial cells in your body and your brain
that wrap around the axons of the
neurons and basically function like
electrical tape for neurons okay so they
are these there's electrical insulation
around the axons of these neurons and
this is provided by another specialized
cell type called a glial cell so this is
by a glial cell okay and here are two
examples of glial cells there are Lego
oligodendrocytes and you can see how
this cells extending processes that wrap
around the axons of these two neurons
here's a Schwann cell over here which
again wraps around the axon and these
cells basically form what's called a
myelin sheath so they form a myelin
sheath around the axons and that
insulates the plasma membrane of the
axon such that so here's a an axon you
have glial cells or wrapped around and
it sort of forms like beads on a string
and so there are these gaps between the
myelin sheath that are known as the note
nodes of ranvier okay so there are these
nodes of ranvier
which are gaps in the myelin sheath and
these nodes perform an important
function for the neuron because where
the axon is wrapped the the membrane is
electrically insulated and so the sodium
ions are the sodium channels and
potassium channels the voltage-gated
ones localized to these nodes and when
the action potential is traveling along
the axon because these regions where the
myelin sheath is are electrically
insulated the axon potential doesn't
just move continuously but jumps from
node to node such that you're just
opening the sodium channels at these
nodes and that allows the action
potential to travel about a hundredfold
faster along the axon and that's what
allows your neurons to transmit these
electrical signals from the base of your
spine to your foot so rapidly okay so
you get an increase in speed because the
action potential is jumping from node to
node and one important reason to bring
this up is because there is a an
important human disease that affects the
electrical insulation in the myelin
sheath here and that's multiple
sclerosis so we're gonna unpack multiple
sclerosis in a couple lectures this is
an autoimmune disorder and so we're
going to talk about immunity later in
the semester and we'll talk about how
that happens but for now I just want to
point out that multiple sclerosis
happens when the immune system attacks
this myelin sheath so in multiple
sclerosis the myelin sheath is damaged
okay and if you damage this electrical
insulation
you greatly slow down these action
potentials and that has a significant
impact on nerve
pulses in the brain and throughout the
entire body and that's why multiple
sclerosis is such a devastating disease
all right I'm gonna start moving now to
consider one more than one neuron so
until now we've just talked about how an
electrical signal is sent along the
length of one cell and now we're gonna
start thinking about multiple neurons
and how they connect and how neurons
integrate information from multiple
other neurons to decide whether or not
to send an action potential okay and so
if we consider this connection right
here there's a synapse right here here's
a sending a cell that's sending
information in the cell that is
receiving that information when we're
considering a synapse so if we consider
a synapse there's a cell that is sending
the signal which is called the pre
synapse this is the sender cell and
there's a postsynaptic cell okay but you
can have more than one neuron sending a
signal to a neuron at this at a given
time
right so here you have one neuron there
it's sending a signal at this synapse
but you might have another neuron
sending a signal to a synapse on this
part of the cell and you could have
another signal coming in here and so
this this neuron will then have to
decide whether or not to fire an action
potential down its axon okay and the way
that the neuron decides this is to
integrate the signals so there's a
signal integration process and what's
important for signal integration in a
neuron is whether or not the cell body
whether the voltage increases above a
certain threshold potential so if the
cell body doesn't increase if the
voltage doesn't increase
above this potential there will be no
action potential fired but if the action
if the voltage increases above the
threshold potential then it fires the
action potential and signals to a
downstream neuron or muscle or another
cell okay so here it is the threshold
potential in the cell body that
determines whether or not an action
potential is sent down the axon okay and
there are different types of signals
that nerve cells can send so there are
different types of signals signals can
be excitatory meaning it deep will tend
to depolarize the neuron so there are
excitatory signals which results in
depolarization for example with
serotonin that opens a sodium channel
and that results in depolarization so
that's an excitatory signal but there
are other types of signals that bind to
different types of receptors that are
inhibitory what might be a type of
receptor that would inhibit this process
of sending an action potential
what might an inhibitory receptor be to
make sure to lower the chance that this
action potential will be fired
what if I told you it's it's an ion
channel what ion would you expect it
might pass pseudo
potassium Uno is exactly right right if
you test if it passes potassium then
it's gonna it's gonna make the inside
more negative and that's what's known as
hyperpolarization so receptors that
result in hyperpolarization would have
an inhibitory effect on this process
okay right and remember if your
hyperpolarizing then you're gonna you
could cause this to actually go down and
get even farther away from this
threshold potential right and if you
have an activating signal and an
inhibitory signal they might cancel out
because one will depolarize in the other
will hyperpolarize so it's in this way
and neuron is able to integrate signals
coming from different neurons and that
influences whether or not it will send
the signal to a downstream a cell okay
so now we're focusing on what is the
communication between one neuron and
another and this revolves around this
thing that's called the synapse which is
basically the gap between the axon
terminal of one neuron and the dendrites
of a postsynaptic neuron okay and so the
way that multiple neurons communicate
with each other are through a type of
signal known as a neurotransmitter okay
and this is what initiates the signal so
there's a signal initiation process at
the synapse initiation and then this
involves the presynaptic neuron
secreting a neurotransmitter so the
signal in this case signals between
neurons are called neurotransmitters and
as you see on the slide these are
examples of neurotransmitters they're
often derived from amino acids and so
there's small molecules they're not the
proteins that you often see with
receptor tyrosine kinase ligands this is
a different class of signal
so one example is serotonin and if you
look up at those will find serotonin
here there it is here you can see it's a
derivative of tryptophan okay so it's a
small molecule and it's able to bind to
a receptor on the postsynaptic cell and
induce depolarization okay and so
neurons are the way that they
communicate as neurons are a case of
where luck favors the prepared
neurons are totally prepared to send
signals to each other they have
everything ready to go when they get
word from from upstream and they're
ready to send signals to their next cell
okay and that's because if we look at
the synapse prior to an action potential
everything is ready to go
the cell has neurotransmitter and it's
packaged in these vesicles and it's
tethered to the plasma membrane ready to
be released
okay so prior to the action potential
there are vesicles filled with
neurotransmitter that are docked at the
plasma membrane I abbreviate plasma
membrane p.m. just so I don't have to
write it out okay so these contain
neurotransmitter right but you see in
this dock vesicle the neurotransmitter
is in red and it can't get out if that
vesicle does not fuse with the plasma
membrane okay so these contain
neurotransmitter
but at this point the vesicles have
infused but the vesicles not fused okay
when should they fuse in this system of
neurons signaling to each other when
should these the vesicle fused with the
plasma membrane
what should trigger the fusion process
yes miles yeah so miles is exactly right
right if we consider my diagram here
right there's an action potential
traveling along this axon when it gets
to the axon terminus that should be that
fits the signal for these vesicles
diffuse to the plasma membrane and to
release neurotransmitter okay so the
arrival of the action potential right so
remember so in this case serotonin is
going to be in blue right if serotonin
is inside my vesicle here is going to
need to exocytosis and now the serotonin
is going to be outside the cell ready to
bind to the receptor okay all right so
as Miles pointed out you have an action
potential the fusion should be triggered
by the action potential in order to fuse
there needs to be some signal inside the
cytoplasm to tell the vesicle to fuse
that signal is increased calcium ion
concentration and then when calcium
concentration increases in the cytoplasm
that triggers the fusion of these
vesicles and when you get fusion there's
that's exocytosis and the serotonin is
now on the outside of the cell where it
can travel across the synaptic
and bind to a receptor on the
postsynaptic neuron okay so this fusion
is when neurotransmitter is released
neurotransmitter is released here okay
in the way that this increasing calcium
has to happen when the action potential
arrives at the axon terminus so when it
arrives in the axon terminus there's
depolarization of that part of the cell
and so there's a special type of protein
called a voltage-gated calcium channel
right these all these channels are very
selective for different ions so a
voltage-gated sodium channel isn't
letting in all the ions outside the cell
it's selective to sodium and this case
this voltage-gated calcium channel is
just gonna let in calcium and then
there's a mechanism that links calcium
entry to vesicle fusion and that's going
to be shown here what you see on this
docked synaptic vesicle is this calcium
binding protein called sanic
synaptotagmin that's present on the
vesicle and so when calcium goes into
the cytoplasm that protein binds to
calcium and it activates the fusion
machinery such that the plasma membrane
of the vesicle fuses or the membrane of
the vesicle fuses with the plasma
membrane of the cell thus releasing the
neurotransmitter into the synaptic cleft
okay so this is this is what starts the
signal now you probably know that you're
you're these neurons are not active or
on all the time so something has to
terminate the signal usually quite
rapidly okay so now I want to talk about
that
so like all signaling pathways signaling
is useless if you can just turn it on
you have to be able to toggle it on and
off in order for biological systems to
function properly right and that's the
case with neurons if you just turn on a
neuron and you don't have a way to turn
it back off again then that's pretty
useless okay and so we have to have a
way to turn off the signal and if we
consider the synapse this is the
presynaptic neuron here I'm going to
draw a postsynaptic neuron here and
neurotransmitter is released by the
presynaptic neuron this is the
postsynaptic neuron here
neurotransmitter is released into the
synaptic cleft okay so this the region
the sort of extracellular region between
these two neurons is called the synaptic
cleft so now the cell just dumped a
whole buttload of neurotransmitter into
the synaptic cleft right how is it going
to turn this off what does it have to do
yeah Stephen
[Music]
so Stevens exactly right what Steven
suggested is is there a way for the
presynaptic neuron to reabsorb this
neurotransmitter and thus recycle it
okay and so there's so I could either
reabsorb it or degrade the
neurotransmitter it's a different
process for different neurotransmitters
for serotonin there are channels that
are present in the plasma membrane and
these mediate reuptake of the serotonin
okay
so you have channels that are basically
after the neurotransmitter is released
it sucks the neurotransmitter back into
the presynaptic cell such that it can
then sort of reuse the neurotransmitter
later on okay and so this process of
reuptake highlights a very important or
an important process that's been
utilized by drug companies to create
antidepressants so antidepressants like
prozac and zoloft effect this reuptake
process and what that does is it keeps
the neurotransmitter in the synaptic
cleft for longer such as it enhances the
signaling and so the idea behind these
drugs is that if you are suffering
depression from a lack of serotonin then
you can rescue that by preventing the
rapid real take of the neurotransmitter
into the cell after the synapse is
stimulated and the neurotransmitter is
released okay and so prozac Zoloft these
are a class of drugs that are known as
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors
serotonin reuptake
inhibitors it's kind of a mouthful
this is abbreviated SSRIs okay but the
way they function is to leave the
neurotransmitter in the synaptic cleft
for longer so that you enhance signaling
even if you have low levels of the
neurotransmitter to begin with I also
want to point out that if we look at
this diagram here the synaptic vesicle
fuses and then this releases the
neurotransmitter but all the machinery
on this vesicle is recycled by
endocytosis such that it can be reused
again okay
so cells are really good at recycling
stuff right if this is sort of the
membrane to you endocytosis and then you
can use it again later on okay and so
there's recycling not only of the
neurotransmitter but also all of the
machinery on these synaptic vesicles
that are responsible for the fusion
event all right now I want to end by
just telling you how this experiment
works where we're able to activate
specific neurons in a brain and that
leads to the animal sort of waking up
okay so in a normal neuron so this is
the last part optogenetics and I'm gonna
go through this very fast but normally
you need a neurotransmitter to induce
depolarization but what optogenetics is
is an approach to control the activity
of a cell with light okay so in this
case we're gonna have light inducing
depolarization and the way this is done
is there's a protein discovered from
from photosynthetic algae that's
responsive to light and it is a sodium
channel and this protein is called
channelrhodopsin
specifically CHR - and this is a
light-sensitive protein where light
induces sodium channel opening okay so
that's gonna depolarize the cell and
what you can do is if you have a gene
that you know is specifically expressed
in a certain type of neuron you can take
the promoter and enhancer region of that
gene and hook it up to this single
component channelrhodopsin that open
reading frame using recombinant DNA
technology and if that's expressed
specifically in the neurons that you're
trying to test you can then shine a
light into the brain of the organism and
activate specifically this type of
neuron and that allows you to test the
function of the neuron in the behavior
of an organism so in this case this
mouse the light is shined into its brain
and they're testing a specific type of
neuron that is involved in arousal of
the mouse and it wakes up oh it's not
playing so here this is the this is a no
this is the brain activity on the top
and the muscle activity on the bottom so
you're gonna see light there's the light
you see it light going into the brain
there they induce light at that
frequency for a while and then they're
gonna wait and see the mouse see if when
the mouse wakes up and it's gonna wake
up right now there it goes
woke up you see now it's muscle activity
is going okay so you can test the
function of specific nerve cells using
this approach and it's because you have
a light-sensitive sodium channel so I'm
done for today have a great weekend I
will see you on Monday
you